[Music]
as strange as the creatures of the
microcosmos are
their lives still revolve around the
same fundamentals that ours do
there's food there's reproduction
and there's death
yes even microbes hearty as they can be
experienced death in some ways
you could say they invented it
and so on our journey through the
microcosmos we have watched those deaths
through many lenses some are slow calm
affairs while others are explosive or
creepy and today we're gonna try
something new for our channel we have
gathered a few of our favorite episodes
about death in the micro cosmos so that
we can see
where our journey has taken us so yeah
this is the kind of video that you can
turn on and leave on for a while
this first video is also one of our
oldest so you'll notice that a lot of
footage in it looks pretty different
from what we show these days because
thanks to the support of our viewers we
have been able to upgrade our microscope
multiple times over the course of this
show
so the microscope may be different but
the death
well the death remains the same
[Music]
this round little unicellular creature
came to us via a plankton net a mesh
with tiny microscopic holes through
which we ran hundreds and hundreds of
liters of water letting us collect
anything too large to pass through
we haven't been able to identify this
species yet making it a bit of a mystery
but the bigger mystery is still to come
because this little creature
is about to undergo that most universal
and unknowable experience of all
death
[Music]
death comes to the microcosmos in many
forms like this stenter polymorphis
slowly expelling the contents of its
once trumpet-like body into the
surrounding environment or this dead
larvae whose exoskeleton is now an
inanimate host to two unicellular
organisms
even the mighty tardigrade which has
survived as a species through multiple
mass extinctions is not immune to death
[Music]
this is
of course
the natural order of things
predators hunt and their prey attempts
to survive with
varying levels of success
this is loxophilum meliagris a large
unicellular organism that we've shown
before eating a rotifer this one is
practically stuffed with those
multicellular creatures we counted five
rotifers inside of it but sometimes the
predator becomes the prey
and even the
meliagris has to find ways to ensure
survival when other species come after
it
this seemingly unlikely threat is the
lacrimaria oler its name in latin means
tears of a swan
a name that suits both its teardrop
shape and its neck like extension which
gets up to eight times longer than its
body in search of prey
sometimes we can see its neck poking out
of the dirt on our microscope slide but
even knowing that you'd be forgiven for
thinking that it's unlikely that
something so small
could pose a problem for those larger
locks of film and yet
the lacrimaria manages to take quite a
chunk out of the loxophilum
the lock the film though survives thanks
to its ability to regenerate the peace
that was taken
but not all prey
get so lucky
here this rotifer has been killed by a
heliozoin destined to become food a fate
that this flagellate is about to share
as it becomes captured by a heliozoin
that is in the middle of cell division
the flagellate has been trapped by those
long extensions called axopods that
radiate out from the heliosoen's body as
the flagellate comes further in it will
be engulfed by the cells into its own
food compartment called a vacuole there
it will be lysed open and its contents
digested by the heliozoa
in the end though the natural order
comes for predators too here another
helios owen's dying cellular body
attracts the various decomposers of the
microbial world
aside from predators there are many
other factors that lead a single celled
organism to die
changes in temperature oxygen
concentration ph water quality so much
more
this single-celled organism is swollen
because the water surrounding it is
entering the cell via osmosis
many organisms have water pumps called
contractile vacuoles that they use to
push water back out and prevent that
swelling
but as in the case of this organism
sometimes those contractile vacuoles
stop working and when that happens the
cell swells
and explodes
[Music]
other times the cause of death is harder
to determine like this peridoleptus that
spent several hours swimming before
going still
its shape beginning to change until it
melts away
seeming to kill not only the
peridoleptus but this small green cell
swimming nearby
but leaving other smaller flagellates
seemingly unaffected
and this
brings us back to the beginning
with our mystery organism that is about
to undergo a death laden with even more
mysteries
at first the cell looks like it's just
melting away
dissolving into something that resembles
a microbial milky way
except that
for a few seconds
it almost looks like the cell membrane
is able to close itself back up
we think
though we can't know for sure that some
of the mechanisms inside this cell are
still working
and that the organism is trying to
recover but alas
survival
is not in the cards
its membrane goes through lysis
releasing its insides to the surrounding
environment
this death
is unlike any other kind of death we
have observed under our microscope
and we're still not sure what caused it
perhaps there were so many organisms in
this sample that they depleted the
oxygen and this organism couldn't
continue cellular respiration
but perhaps
it was something else
death at every size
holds its own mysteries but it also
reveals
the observations we make even the
guesses we come up with tell us about
the way these microbes interact with
their environment the way their bodies
work and the connections that exist
between them
it is only ever in the mysteries that
knowledge
is waiting to be found
[Music]
so we just saw a small fraction of how
many ways there are for microbes to die
but maybe now you're asking yourself a
more fundamental question
what even is death
well weirdly none of us will ever fully
know the answer to that question but
that does not mean that we can't try to
use what we know of chemistry and life
to begin to describe it as we will see
in our next video
[Music]
this
is aciliate luxodi's magnus
it is about to die
of course depending on your time scale
we are all about to die to the grand
canyon or the sun
things that have existed for millions or
billions of years
we are each weird little bubbles of
peculiar chemistry that form
and then pop form
and then pop
but this cilliate and with our new
microscope you can really see those
cilia beating is about to pop right
before your eyes
it looks fine right now
you can even see inside at its last meal
a tracolimonis so we don't think it's
starving to death
it seems to be trucking along just fine
luxoty's magnus are microaerophilic
organisms preferring a low concentration
of dissolved oxygen in their environment
but not too low
so maybe the concentration on the slide
was too high
though we've witnessed many others who
have been just fine in our preparations
so no
we can't tell you why this ciliate is
about to die
but we can tell you that
right here
that's where james our master of
microscopes
first saw something strange
the moment the ciliate shifted direction
a little trail of cell membrane and
cytoplasm
no reason
nothing grabbed it
it didn't snag on anything
but a little bit of what was once part
of the organism
was suddenly
no longer a part of it
that cytoplasm is full of complicated
molecules that are what chemists would
call
far from equilibrium
[Music]
equilibrium is the situation in which
chemicals no longer have a tendency to
react over time
in general a thing that you can say for
sure
is that all the stuff outside of living
cells is either at chemical equilibrium
or it is headed there
whereas stuff inside cells
is not at equilibrium and it's not
headed there either
how
are all these chemicals that if left
alone would rapidly reach equilibrium
managing to not do that
life
that
is what life is
a bunch of chemicals
that take in energy in order to keep
each other from reaching equilibrium
[Music]
quick break from our friend
the way we define life in biology
classes is wrong
it's not even really a definition it's a
set of qualifying factors life has to
take in energy life has to reproduce it
must respond to its environment it must
consist of cells
this is not a definition it's an attempt
to draw a line to create a boundary
and that makes sense for things that are
actually amorphous and complicated like
social constructs
but life is not a construct of our
opinions
but of reality life
is a chemical system that uses energy to
keep itself from reaching chemical
equilibrium
why did they do it
well maybe let's not go that deep at
least not today suffice it to say a
system that did this developed on this
planet and now
billions of years later
it is still
doing it
we have many things in common with this
ciliate and not to belabor the point but
one of those things is that we will die
you've probably noticed by now that this
video
isn't about what life is
it's about what death is it's just that
first
we had to define life
life is chemicals working together to
take in energy to keep themselves far
from equilibrium
death
is not the return to chemical
equilibrium the process of decay can
last decades
likewise
many parts of my body will return to
equilibrium over the course of my life
i'm shedding skin cells right now and so
are you
the atoms and molecules of my body are
replaced with new ones over and over and
over again
but i will only die
once
likewise our ciliate has been shedding
cytoplasm and cell membrane for minutes
now
and that shed cytoplasm is dead no doubt
but the organism lives
its chemistry continues
for now
death
is the moment when the system that
maintains the far from equilibrium state
ceases existence and we can imagine that
at many scales that can happen to
individual bits of an organism as it is
happening to the chemicals spilling out
of our luxodies right now
it can also happen to an individual cell
in an organism and that happens all the
time it is happening right now
inside you it can also happen to an
organism that's what we usually think of
as death with our focus so often on the
individual but we can keep moving up the
scale and find yet other kinds of death
when a common genetic system that was
useful for keeping many similar but
individual organisms alive ceases to
exist
that
is an extinction a kind of death
and when the system that has kept all
life on earth far from equilibrium for
billions of years
that system that we all share of nucleic
and amino acids
when that ceases to exist
that
will be something else
a terrible kind of death
that we do not even have a name for
but it will be a death
the largest death i suppose until heat
death
when everything in the universe has
found equilibrium
[Music]
our ciliate
is about out of time now
i don't know when we can call it when we
can pronounce the time of death
but this seems as good a time as any
here
we have death
the system that was using energy to keep
itself from reaching equilibrium
has ceased to exist
[Music]
welcome back uh if you've come out of
that video with some existential dread
about the state of the universe that is
very reasonable however on our next stop
in this journey we're gonna argue that
sure chemical equilibria are scary but
if you're a nematode maybe you should
worry about fungi first
[Music]
[Music]
there are plenty of horror stories that
begin
innocuously enough a new home a camping
trip with friends
a doll purchased at an estate sale
this one
starts with some ponds
the same set of ponds that james our
master of microscopes has been sampling
every week for the past three years
which means that he's collected so many
microbes from these waters that you
might think they'd get a bit boring or
redundant
but you should never underestimate
nature's capacity for surprise
[Music]
recently james came home with some
samples from these ponds and as usual
he prepared some slides and checked on
the organisms within
finding some nematodes like this one
slithering about on the slide
and all seemed well
so he stored the slides and his new
friends in a humidity chamber
and waited to observe them after a few
more days
but two days later
all would not be well
this
is where we build our suspense in a
movie this would be the moment where we
assess the unsettling basement or the
dark woods and then consider retreating
to safety this is the creepy doll only
there hasn't been any thumps in the
middle of the night
so everything seems okay right
we're looking at the spores of a fungus
one belonging to the group arthrobotras
and when it's just floating around like
this seems quite harmless
especially when compared to the
nematodes we showed earlier which are
part of a whole family of worms that are
notorious for their parasitic lifestyle
and if you were to write off
arthrobotras as a potential threat you
would be
correct
most of the time
it does spend much of its life aligned
with the dead but only to sustain itself
on the remains of decayed life and
organic matter
arthrobotra species are found all around
the world occupying everything from soil
to animal feces and the many varied
climates that make up our planet and
wherever it is the fungus ensures that
nutrients like nitrogen from dead
organisms and other waste cycle through
ecosystems but when nitrogen is scarce
these fungi will resort to hunting it
down
from living sources
and what better prey than the nematode a
fellow dweller of the soil and one of
the most abundant animals on earth
when james put his slides into the
humidity chamber he had no notion of
what these nematodes would be facing and
so
no expectation
of what he would find
but when the slides came back out
what he observed was something
he'd only seen once before
in a drawing done two years ago by one
of his close friends caitlyn solback
in it
you can see a nematode whose body has
been clinched into segments by some kind
of bulbous
thing
what you're seeing is the fungus's most
brutal design but to get there it must
morph from decomposer
to predator
no longer consuming what has already
been dead but actively
killing
it begins
by weaving a trap out of itself
it threads the hyphy of its mycelium out
and then back in forming a living loop
that repeats to form a net
but a net is only one part of a trap the
other part
is the lure
the fungi can find nematodes by
following traces of their pheromones
like their breadcrumbs
and more nefariously they can mimic the
smell of certain food cues to draw the
worm in like a siren working through
scent instead of song
the nematode has no reason to suspect
anything even as it swims closer and
closer and eventually through the fungal
rings but as it does
the movement of worm and water triggers
the rings to constrict
the worm is trapped
but the worst
is still yet to come
the fungus is hyphy begin to grow off
from the loop puncturing the worm's
cuticle and paralyzing it the threads
swell up into a bulb that produces more
hyphae to spread through the rest of the
nematode and then the fungus feeds
and feeds quickly digesting the rest of
the nematodes body
from within
[Music]
it is a gruesome death
here is one nematode just recently
trapped
and here is the worm again
four days later
you can see the infection bulb where the
fungus first punctured and expanded
and the whole body of the worm seems
taken over no longer a clear tube but
instead a corpse that has become home to
its cause of death
the arthrobotra's fungi
are not the only ones capable of
trapping and feeding upon nematodes
there's a whole range of nematode
trapping fungi with their own methods
though the species arthrobatrus
oligospora is perhaps the most plentiful
of these fungi and also the best studied
maybe it's just us
but it's somewhat unsettling to realize
that this insidiousness is all the work
of a fungus
a thing that can seem so inert compared
to the
wiggling active
worm that it targets
but fungi do have a kinship with horror
stories their frequent role as
decomposers naturally connect them with
the dead
plus they come equipped with their own
creeping sense of dread with images of
mycelia weaving through bodies
and authors have drawn inspiration from
the notion of fungal horror there are
many works like the famous gothic tale
we have always lived in the castle or
the short story the voice in the night
or recent novels like mexican gothic and
wanderers that draw on everything from
poisonous mushrooms to colonizing fungi
to create their terror
but whatever we seek to scare ourselves
with in fiction
horror has its purpose in nature
as we've pointed out nematodes are one
of the most abundant animals on earth
they play an important role in
decomposition but they're also the
source of many diseases both in animal
bodies and in plants
so having them be slightly less abundant
is important to our ecosystem as well
in fact scientists have been studying
these fungi to develop better nematode
fighting strategies for
agriculture so as is the case with many
good horror villains
there's a version of this story where
the nematode trapping fungus
is the hero
unless of course
you're the nematode
[Music]
and for our last video our microbes are
dying at the hands of an unusual enemy
it is james with a uv laser in the
laboratory
maybe it sounds like a microscopic
version of the game clue but there is a
point to it all we swear
[Music]
have appeared on our channel several
times before in fact this channel got
its start thanks to a video that james
our master of microscopes once posted of
a blepharisma dying
around 3 million people watched that
video including me your host hank green
so if you enjoy this channel you can
thank that dead blepharisma
but perhaps you should wait for another
day to thank them because in about 10
seconds you're gonna watch a blepharisma
explode
here it is
glowing with autofluorescence underneath
uv light you can see its oblong shape
and oral groove outlined in red but not
for long
the red becomes brighter and brighter
but it also looks like it's starting to
expand
and then suddenly the walls of the
blepharism burst the organism
popping like a crimson balloon
the blepharism bubbles and pours into
its surroundings and it all happens
within a matter of seconds
let's watch it again
[Music]
[Music]
dead or dying microbes are a common
enough sight in our journey through the
microcosmos and there are many potential
culprits behind these deaths predators
accidents environmental changes the
inevitable march of life into death but
the culprit this time
well
it was us
us and the uv light that is part of our
new fluorescence microscope upgrade and
our uv light has been very exciting for
us in particular it's allowed us to look
for methanogens or archaea which
sometimes take up residence inside
protists under normal light it's hard to
tell the tiny archaea and the tiny
bacteria apart but under uv light the
archaea will shine blue
so uv can reveal new aspects of the
micro cosmos but if you've ever fallen
asleep on a beach or just stayed out in
the sun of it too long you may have also
experienced
the darker side of uv light
no one wants a sunburn but fortunately
we have defenses like hair and melanin
and sunscreen which can block or absorb
uv rays before they cause further damage
in our cells
we also and this is crucial
have more than one cell so if some of
them die which when you get a sunburn
they do the rest of our bodies can live
on not all organisms have these sorts of
protections or if they do they're
designed for exposure to the sun
not the intense scrutiny of our uv light
[Music]
so when james wants to haunt archaea he
has to be careful he can quickly shine
the uv light to see if anything blue
appears but he has to quickly shut it
off
because as we've seen
even a few seconds of exposure to the uv
light will kill off his pond buddies we
want to note that as we said earlier
death is a common reality of the
microcosmos we just usually prefer to
walk in on a microbe dying rather than
being the cause of death but for this
episode we decided to make an exception
and use our uv light for an extended
period of time with the knowledge that
it would kill the microbe we were
watching
because these explosions illustrate the
cost of doing business with light
the word for this business is photo
toxicity
death by light and while it can happen
under monochromatic light the particular
wavelength and intensity of our uv light
makes it much more harmful to our
organisms than our other red blue or
green light sources this death starts
with excitation
when the light hits the organism it can
potentially excite chemical structures
inside the cell sending electrons up and
down and producing fluorescent colors in
the process
but the colors aren't the only thing
that gets created if there's oxygen
around it will react with the excited
fluorescent molecule creating what are
known as reactive oxygen
in biology reactive oxygen species are
byproducts of different cellular
processes that metabolize oxygen which
can make them part of normal life there
are even reactive oxygen species that
are involved in signaling pathways but
the reactive in their name is key to
what makes an excess amount of them
dangerous
if you are an organism and you are there
are a lot of reactions you want to have
happen in your cells you want your dna
to link together correctly you want your
enzymes to find the right substrates
but reactive oxygen species are happy to
react with all of those molecules too
damaging them and getting in the way of
the chemistry that we need
to survive
what phototoxicity will look like
depends on the organism and the light
being directed at it
[Music]
for the organisms we've been showing
here like this homolozoan the overall
effect of this intense uv light seems to
be unanimous the cell swells up and
bursts open like a galaxy erupting on
our slide
but while the overall effect is the same
the internal machinations are likely
different triggered by a complex
interplay of different chemicals that
nonetheless react to our light source in
a similar catastrophic fashion
while we're not sure of the culprits
behind the homolozoans death we can
identify one of the chemicals that
likely sets off the blepharisma's death
it's the reddish pigment molecule called
blepharisman that gives the ciliate its
color under more normal circumstances
outside of the uv light you can see the
membrane-bound pigments neatly
distributed along the rows that stretch
from one end of the blepharism to the
other
but under our uv light and with oxygen
in the environment the blepharisman
reacts to form a reactive oxygen species
and death follows quickly from there
but while toxic in our experiment we
should note that the blepharisman serves
a key purpose for the blepharisma
defense these pigment molecules are
toxic to some of blepharitis predators
in both the light and the dark
that makes the pigment somewhat like uv
light necessary for survival yet also a
delicate negotiation
but in the same way that we manage our
relationship with the sun scientists
have learned ways to manage these
phototoxic reactions they've had to in
order to understand how we can use
fluorescence microscopy to study cells
and organisms they've learned how to
modulate wavelength and intensity and
duration along with many other factors
to wield light in a way that better
serves their purposes
in the case of the blepharisma for
example scientists found that using a
moderate light for around one hour
wasn't much of a problem for them but
with more time under the light the cells
would eventually die
it's easy to think of the microcosmos as
a separate world from us even when we
know that the microscope is a bridge
between large and small
but these deaths at the hand of our
supposed bridge
are a cautionary sign that we are
encountering microbes in a world that is
both natural and manufactured at the
same time
the way that we light that world impacts
the way we see the organisms and it also
shapes their lives reminding us that
they are stronger often than we can
fathom
but fragile nonetheless
[Music]
and that brings us to the end of our
tour of death in the micro cosmos today
an end to a story of ends you might say
but maybe what we've seen today
is that there really is no end is there
just pauses on individual stories that
nonetheless endure in the remains of the
world
left behind
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you as always to all of our
patrons who make videos like the ones
that we have watched today possible
this channel could not exist without
your support and we are so thankful for
it so if you would like to join the list
of patrons you are currently seeing on
your screen you can go to patreon.com
journey2micro
and if you'd like to see more from our
master of microscopes james you can
check out jam and germs on instagram
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you